here in London there is always a famous
person you're gonna find and here we
have with us the legendary Grandmaster
Nigel short British legend World
Championship candidate one of the top
players of the world for many years and
Nigel it must be great to have the
London chess classic here in your
hometown this is a place that your
stomping grounds well actually I've been
living in Greece for quite a long time a
couple of decades already but yeah I do
feel it's also my hometown and I still
have a flat here in fact so no it's a
great event
I love the ambience I love seeing so
many people of different ages many
different levels all here you know and
from the very best down to beginners we
see the places of buzz I mean you get a
sense of this amazing atmosphere it's
not a just a chest or emits a festival
it is yeah and it's been building up
over the over the years with a lot of
careful work and it gets bigger and
better with each year what do you think
about the players here I mean these are
players of course it's you've played
many of them and some of the young ones
who have come on the scene as well the
strongest tournament in British history
yeah well obviously it's a delight to
see these games unfortunately I bet I've
been a bit preoccupied with my own knock
out tournaments and we've had quite a
grueling schedule so we play two games
on the first day and then I had playoffs
I was playing until late at night we
know you defeated Luke McCain 2-0 so
you're on to the finals I'm on to the
final so I've booked my place here for
the next for the next week and I'm very
pleased about that so now I'll see what
I can do against David Howell who is a
very tough competitor but now things
will settle down a little bit and a more
regular schedule so I'm looking forward
to seeing a bit more of the top event
finally tell us about the future
or your hopes at least for the future of
British chess with events like this the
Chester the schools and communities
program it's it's interesting because
actually the amount of chess activity
has risen quite significantly over the
past few years I mean this this is a
great event we don't have enough of them
and also we don't seem to be producing
really top junior players and that's an
issue which we need to address so it's
aging veterans like myself there are
some good younger players but we don't
have this like in the United States now
you have a lot of very talented young
players coming coming through with
examples like you we hope to see a lot
more players come up the legend Nigel
short one of the great players of our
generation still busy doing his work now
on to the finals of the British of the
knockout the London chess
knockout we'll see how he does as the
pin games continue guys